Hi, and welcome to the first of several lessons on tools of the trade. I'm
very excited about these lessons, because I believe that tools are a cornerstone
of the software engineering discipline, and it
is of paramount importance to know and
use them. In this lesson, we will
talk about integrated development environments, normally called IDEs.
And these are software applications that support developers in many of their
everyday tasks, such as writing, compiling, and debugging code. And to make the
discussion more concrete we will focus on a specific IDE, Eclipse. We will
first present Eclipse, and then get some hands-on experience through a demo.